en este vídeo queremos encontrar una
relación entre el área de un triángulo y
el radio de su círculo déjame pintar por
aquí el cirque un círculo del triángulo
porque va a ser más fácil hacerlo así y
por aquí el triángulo va entonces
tenemos un triángulo más o menos algo
así supongamos que se ve algo de este
estilo que este vértice se llama
estevez estevez y este de aquí es se
vale y que este lado se llama a
minúscula bueno tiene longitud a
minúscula este se llama b minúscula y
este s minúscula bueno entonces queremos
encontrar una relación entre el área del
triángulo y el radio del circo un
círculo o sea decir un radio vamos a
empezar con el área para determinar el
área del triángulo a bs vamos a
necesitar una altura entonces déjame
dibujarla por aquí entonces debe vamos a
bajar una altura a ac vamos a pensar que
aquí llega a un punto
a un punto y digamos que esta altura
mide h h ok entonces sabemos por la
fórmula del área de un triángulo que el
área de este triángulo el área del
triángulo abc que se denota con
corchetes
a veces es igual a un medio un medio de
la base por la altura aquí la base sería
b minúscula y un medio de b b minúscula
x h x h muy bien ahora vamos a empezar
un poco en términos del cirque un
círculo aquí tenemos el círculo que es
el conjunto de puntos que distan del
círculo centro y el radio es decir un
radio la distancia de este punto a los
vértices de acá bueno lo que vamos a
hacer es que vamos a tomar un diámetro
que pase por b es decir tenemos que
tomar una recta que pase por b y por el
centro déjame tomar la herramienta de
recta para que se vea más más bonita
entonces creo que algo así
tiene que ir un poco más para acá
si está bien vale entonces tomamos un
diámetro por b y entonces ese diámetro
pasa por este punto deja de llamarle o
al circo un centro vale bueno aquí al
punto diametralmente opuesto debe vamos
a llamarle t y lo que vamos a hacer es
que vamos a construir el triángulo a b d
entonces déjame trazar esta esta otra en
este otro segmento de aquí vale bueno
observa que tenemos los triángulos abed
y bs voy a mostrar que esos dos
triángulos son semejantes y para eso
vamos a utilizar varias de las cosas que
ya vimos vale aquí como tenemos un
diámetro b de entonces el ángulo b a d
es un ángulo de 90 grados
esto lo mostramos en en algunos de los
vídeos de la lista de geometría pero la
prueba no era muy difícil ya lo podemos
pensar así
este es un ángulo inscrito que tiene que
ver con este arco de acá pero este arco
mide 180 grados porque claramente aquí
tenemos una línea recta verdad entonces
este de aquí mide la mitad de 180 grados
y por lo tanto es un ángulo de 90
grados bueno entonces aquí tenemos 90
grados pero observa observa que además
este arco de aquí este ángulo de aquí
está suspendido por dos ángulos
inscritos para empezar este ángulo
inscrito de aquí sub tiende al arco ave
y además este ángulo inscrito de aquí
también se tiende al arco ave entonces
estos dos ángulos tienen que ser iguales
ambos son iguales a la mitad de la
longitud de este arco vale bueno pues
eso nos va a permitir concluir que los
triángulos ave de jbc son semejantes
porque observa tienen un ángulo recto
ambos aquí está en nada y aquí estén y
además tienen el ángulo naranja en común
el ade b es congruente al s b entonces
son dos ángulos o dos triángulos con dos
ángulos en común por lo tanto el tercero
también tiene que ser igual al tercero
éste aquí es igual este de acá y por lo
tanto son dos triángulos semejantes vale
déjame apuntarlo por acá tenemos que el
triángulo el triángulo abb
de es semejante al triángulo de bs al
triángulo
b c y estoy aquí es por el criterio
ángulo ángulo ángulo ángulo bueno esto
está padre porque ahora vamos a poder
escribir las razones entre los lados de
estos triángulos con una cierta relación
verdad entonces déjame escribir cómo
quedaría tenemos que se entrevé de este
es este lado entre la hipotenusa y la
hipotenusa es simplemente dos veces el
círculo radio verdad entonces lo voy a
poner por acá lo voy a poner en color
dos con este azul de la semejanza
tenemos que se hace entre el diámetro o
sea dos veces el círculo radio es igual
a y vamos a los lados correspondientes
aquí tenemos este lado que es el rey
entre el recto y el verde que sería este
este de aquí entre el recto y el verde
entonces sería el correspondiente sería
h dividido entre la hipotenusa aquí la
hipotenusa es 12 r pero en el pequeño la
hipotenusa mide a entonces sería h
/ a muy bien entonces aquí ya tenemos
una relación con ave h&r y aquí tenemos
otra que tiene al área b&h entonces se
ve que ya estamos en el último jalón
verdad ya nada más tenemos que de alguna
forma substituir el valor de h aquí
abajo y con eso terminaríamos como le
vamos a hacer podríamos despejar h aquí
y luego ponerlo así vamos a hacer eso
vamos a despejar h de este término va
entonces para despejar h debemos
deshacernos de él un medio de b para eso
déjame multiplicar por 2 b por 2 entre b
perdón 2 entre b del lado derecho por 2
entre b del lado izquierdo
aquí la b y el 2 se cancelan y nos queda
el valor de h nos queda que h es igual a
2 veces el área del triángulo abc 2
veces el área del triángulo el triángulo
a b c
a veces dos veces / / / b / b
la longitud del lado del lado hace vale
bueno ahora este valor de h lo podemos
sustituir aquí abajo vamos a ver qué nos
queda nos quedaría voy a tomar otro
color para que no sea tan monótono nos
quedaría que se dividido entre dos veces
el radio es igual a h que es dos veces
el área de el triángulo abc dividido
entre b y todo eso dividido entre al
saleh porque nada más cambie esta h
entonces es todo eso es dividido entre a
y bueno el lado derecho lo podemos
simplificar un poco nos queda dos veces
el área del triángulo abc abc y aquí
estamos dividiendo entre b y luego entre
a y eso es lo mismo que dividir entre
ave tres ave ya nada más falta hacer
algunas manipulaciones algebraicas vamos
a multiplicar el cruzado este ave para
acá y este 12 r para acá entonces nos
quedaría nos quedaría que a veces el
producto de las longitudes de los lados
igual a 2 x 2 es 44 veces r r es decir
un radio x el área de abs simplemente lo
que hicimos fue multiplicar por 12 r por
ave de este lado por 12 r por ave de
este lado este se cancela con este este
se cancela con este y obtenemos esta
expresión va bueno pues ya terminamos
básicamente ahora simplemente hay que
hay que despejar r para eso voy a
multiplicar por ambos lados por el
recíproco de 4 veces el área entonces
multiplicando por eso explicando por eso
me queda aquí pues uno entre cuatro
veces el área de el triángulo abc
de este lado nos queda pues 1 entre 4
veces el área de abc abc de este lado
esto se cancela bueno este y este se
cancelan con este y entonces nos queda
que r voy a agarrar un color brillante
nos queda que r bueno más brillante
todavía nos queda que r
el círculo radio es igual es igual al
producto de los lados es igual a b c /
dividido entre 4 veces 4 veces el área
del triángulo a b c y listo con esto
encontramos una relación entre el
círculo radio y el área del triángulo
abs y también puedes pasar este abc para
acá y el radio acá multiplicando por el
recíproco de abc entre r entonces
también nos queda que el área de abc el
área de abc es igual a el producto a por
b por c dividido entre cuatro veces
cuatro veces el círculo radio y entonces
esto está padre si por alguna razón
tienes
el triángulo abc y la longitud del
círculo radio o la medida decir que un
radio entonces puedes determinar el área